- Hey guys, it's Sam
again, and I just invited
a bunch of my friends over to
watch the Netflix horror film
The Ritual.
It's super terrifying
with a crazy twist ending.
So let's get this thing started.
(screams)
- Oh that is some gory (beeps).
(upbeat music)
- I have seen The Ritual.
You've seen The Ritual too.
- I've seen The Ritual.
- It's about a group of four
guys who get lost in the woods
while hiking, so it's sort
of like Blair Witch Project
but with a modern twist.
- I have not seen The Ritual before
but I love horror movies.
- I also love horror movies
and I have not seen this movie either.
I'm excited.
- Newer horror films I feel aren't as good
as the old ones.
Slowly they're coming back.
- I don't know a lot about horror movies.
But the ones I have seen
I have a lot of reactions.
- What's like a non scary
movie that terrifies you?
- You know that movie The Happening,
that everyone like laughed at it?
I found it very scary.
- Paranormal Activity I couldn't be close
to my closet for a month.
- Why do you want to see
something that makes you
afraid of your closet?
- 'cause I love it.
- I feel like I don't want
something more close to real life
because then I'm like
this could happen to me.
Like I babysit, I could be the babysitter
that picks up the phone and then dies.
- I mean, every person who's
ever babysat has had that fear.
- [Actor] We're hiking.
- To me wanting to go
hiking is a horror movie
in and of itself.
(laughs)
Those are not my friends anymore.
- Yeah.
- There's more where that
(beeps), there's more.
- Who's (beeps) in crying.
(clatters)
- His friend's just hiding.
- Just take it.
- Give him the ring.
- I don't understand people's
attachment to their stuff.
(screams)
- For a wedding ring it's like.
- That's so dumb.
I don't think his wife would be too happy,
like oh you died because
you wouldn't give up
this piece of metal.
- He was trying to
de-escal, because he started
like being like, it's okay.
- It didn't work out for Batman's parents
so why would it work out for you?
- What would you want the friend to do?
That's a genuine question.
- Just throw something, anything.
- He did have a bunch of bottles near by.
- There's so much alcohol near by.
- [All] Yeah.
- [Curly Hair] Oh fair enough.
Fair enough.
- I would totally text
my friends and be like,
yo, there's a dude
inside who has a machete
just like call the cops.
- I would have at least stood next to him
while it was all happening.
- I feel like maybe I would just grab
a bunch of bottles and go for it.
I go, I hide, I'd be like
grab a bunch of bottles
and just start,
and then keep a couple in me and just ram,
like go for the nuts.
Go for the eyes, and
then just (beeps) kick.
- Regardless of what happens
in the rest of the movie,
I would still be pissed
at my friend if they died
and made me feel guilty
to go on a hiking trip.
I think that's awful.
- They're doing it.
- Pouring one out?
- That's the ritual.
- It's their ritual, I don't
know if it's The Ritual.
(laughs)
- How much alcohol is
in that little flask?
- That was one of Mary
Poppin's flasks, right there.
(gasps)
- Oh.
- Oh no.
- How did that even happen?
- What did he just impale himself?
- Did he break something?
- He just like tripped.
- Everybody has like that friend, though.
You know what I mean?
- He's clearly the least athletic one.
- We go southwest through here.
We cut the journey in half.
- What, through the forest?
- Yeah why not?
A little off trail
hiking, could be exciting.
Might even do us some good.
I think we need this.
- I love how he's like,
it's character building
to go through the uncharted forest
with the guy with the meniscus tear.
(laughs)
- Meniscus tear guy.
- That's gonna save our friendship.
- Yeah, remembering their friend.
(screams)
What the (beeps) is that?
- Izzy did two screams.
What the (beeps).
- Jesus Christ.
- It's a massive deer too.
- Yeah, that's not a dear,
that's like a centaur.
- It's a horse.
- Centaur, (laughs).
- Oh look, it's just
started dripping blood.
- Yeah, it's a fresh kill.
- I'm gonna get that tattooed on my ass.
(laughs)
Fresh kill.
- Okay so like we all would
have turned back there, right?
- [All] Yeah.
- We're doing the 14 hours.
- Yeah.
- As soon as a friend
gets injured, be like,
okay guys, we should probably leave.
- Probably a bad sign.
- Well that's why they're
going through the woods
to get to the lodge faster.
- It's already dark
and raining, of course.
(thunders)
- You're going to go into the
random house in the woods?
- They like just saw the haunted emojis
and they're like going.
(laughs)
let's hunker down in the abandoned shack.
- Oh (beeps).
- I'm confused as to what it is.
- I'd rather absolutely
get soaked from head to toe
than go in that cabin.
- I would pitch my tent like
a normal person once again
because a lone cabin in
the woods, it's never good.
- There's either an animal, a bad person,
or as we saw a weird
cult situation happening
and I want no part of that at all.
- Check it out, because it
could be a harmless cabin
that is giving you nice shelter?
This cabin didn't look
harmless from the beginning.
- On the route that we're going,
do they deserve to die at this point?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Poppy] Oh my god.
- I don't think anyone deserves to die.
- [Chloe] Yeah.
- Unless you're like Hitler.
- You're just like.
- They need to go, they're so stupid.
(laughs)
- Expel them from the pop-li-ation.
- Just let it go.
- Scale of one to 10, how
scary is this movie so far?
- I would give it a rising four.
- Rising four, (laughs).
- It's a four right now,
it has potential for more.
(laughs)
- I agree with Emily, it's at
a four but it has potential.
'cause it has like little jump scares.
- I think that whole deer thing
was the scariest thing in it
so I would give it a five because of that.
- I'm at a six, I'm like legit sweating.
- I feel like if I was watching this alone
it would be a soft eight, a hard seven.
(laughs)
- We're soft, we're rising, I feel like
I'm on a porn set or something.
- I'm at like a two, I don't know,
I don't scare very easily.
- Yeah you're making all
the decisions when we go
on our haunted hiking trip.
Is someone gonna die?
- Yes.
- yes, a hundred percent.
- Everyone, maybe.
- [Emily] I think meniscus
guy is the first to go next.
- Ah, he keeps talking
about Gale, his wife.
- He's lame.
He's lame and he's lame.
- I was gonna say he's
lame in so many ways.
(laughs)
let's see what happens next.
(ominous music)
- I'm nervous something's gonna pop.
- Hand on the tree.
- There was?
- I didn't even see it this time.
I saw it last time.
- [All] Oh.
- That's (beeps) huge, what is it?
- They had four different tents, (laughs)
- I'd be huddling together at this point.
- That's a lot.
- Toxic masculinity.
- They can't be near each other.
They were all ready to
like bone in the cabin.
- Yeah.
- And now they're like,
we're in the woods.
- Is it gonna come from behind?
Oh, (laughs)
- [Emily] Oh it's a hand, it's a hand.
- I think it's him.
- Something's gotta happen right now.
- Oh,
- oh.
(gasps)
- Oh no, oh he's just having
his like nightmare things.
- I like this weird nightmare scenario.
- Yeah it's kind of fun.
- It's him, there he is.
- Oh god.
- Oh you were right.
- Yeah, his insides are
gonna be on the floor.
- Oh yup, throw up.
- What do we think is
haunting the forest right now?
- Well I just keep
picturing that tree thing.
Something that's powered by a witch maybe,
like a golem, of sorts.
- Are we still rising?
- I think so, I think
there's still potential.
- The creepiness of the dreams
have heightened it for me.
- It is called The Ritual so I feel
there's still a bigger
part that we're missing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah The Ritual.
(laughs)
we're gonna play a little
round of The Ritual,
would you rather, would
you rather be the lone,
guilty survivor, or the first
person who gets impaled?
- I'd rather be alive no matter what.
- Lone guilty.
- I can't even live with like,
if I said something weird
to someone one time, it haunts me for days
where I'm like, oh my
god did I offend them?
I said that they gave me
a weird look, oh my god,
they hate me now.
Then I have to like journal about it.
- There'll be a lot of
journals if you survive this.
- [Lizzy] I can't survive.
- Everyone else wants to survive.
- Definitely.
- I want to die too.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I don't want to live with that.
- I'd rather not be the one.
- Not the first one to die
too, you definitely want to die
'cause you saw your friends die.
- Would you rather be stuck
with these guys in the woods,
or stuck in the woods with Nic Cage?
- I just watched a really
great Nic Cage movie,
The Family Man, for the first time.
- Yeah.
- So cute, I would be stuck
with him, he was fine.
- As long as Dom's not there, sure.
- Yeah, yeah.
- If you make it out and
you survived with Nic Cage
that's like a great story.
And you're friends for life with Nic Cage
and he's a Coppola so then
you're with the Coppola's.
- Right.
(gasps)
(laughs)
- Oh my (beeps).
- He looks like a hobbit.
(laughs)
- There's golem.
- This is really ineffective running.
- They're running right down the middle
of the whole (beeps) thing too.
- This could be his
lair, the creatures liar.
- I just feel like I'd be
like, oh, another person
perhaps they're on my side.
But clearly that's not the direction
you're supposed to go in.
(dramatic music)
- Good to know there are
like real people living here.
- Very friendly real people.
- Yeah.
Really nice looking.
- Oh,
- oh.
There's a little lady.
They're kind of like modern day hipsters,
like she looks like she
has purple hair now,
cool bowl cut.
- she drank too much kombucha.
- Oh (beeps) they're taking him.
Oh god.
- Oh no he's the weakest link.
- His time has come.
- Guys I feel like this
might be the ritual?
- This seems like it is.
- You know what's crazy
if like without context
this just looks like one of
those Pinterest weddings,
you know what I mean?
- If you just make it a little warmer.
- [Sam] Right it's like
Earth, yeah exactly.
The lighting's a little bit off.
- Oh god.
(moans)
- They're gonna bite his face.
- Oh god.
(screams)
- He's like, I don't want
to go out there anymore.
(screams)
- [Girl] She's pissed.
(laughs and claps)
- She falls heavily to the floor.
- Awesome.
- Oh my god.
- He's gonna have to stare at it.
Look at those eyes.
Ha, he's like, for god's sake.
- [Emily] Just stay down.
- [Poppy] Stay down.
- [Emily] Don't make me hurt you.
- I would totally kneel down,
which I'll do right now.
- I would just yield to it in hopes
that I would be okay.
I'd probably do like a
combo of like fake kneeling.
- I think we've established
I'm a very agreeable person
and would probably do
well in a cult, so yes,
kneel down to the monster.
- We've seen the entire movie now guys,
I want to quick go
through and see like what
you would rate it overall
in terms of scariness,
one through 10, now that
you've seen the whole thing?
- Two.
- Two as well.
- I'd also give it a two.
- If I'm watching it alone, an eight,
if I'm watching it with you guys, a four.
- I still think that was
a six or a seven for me.
I was like scared, we jumped a lot.
- We did yeah.
- The first time I saw it I was so scared,
I'd give it an eight honestly.
- [Sam] We'll go around in a
circle and pitch the bad sequel
to this movie.
- I want to see four of whoever is
the closest female friends of theirs,
go and like try to kill the demon
and see how it does play
out as a female movie.
- If it was four women,
this movie would have ended
like 15 minutes in and
they would have been like.
- They would have been in Tuscany.
- They'd be at the lodge
like enjoying making s'mores.
- Having a laugh.
- Remember we saw that, that was crazy.
- That deer thing was nuts,
good thing we turned around.
- I'm thinking like rom com all the wives
go on a wine trip to Tuscany.
- I love it.
- But then they end up being
pursued by a Italian monster
in the shape of a wine bottle.
(laughs)
- Thanks for joining us
for Spoiler Party today,
be sure to like the video and also comment
what movie you want us to watch next.
(upbeat music)
(whooshes and squeaks)